ça n'est pas une pêche comme les autres
c'est un combat un bras de fer entre
l'homme et le poisson
la traque des bancs de thon rouge se
déroule pendant les mois d'été au large
des côtes basques à la faveur de sa
migration et selon des quotas draconien
les équipages se lance à sa poursuite
une fois sur les bancs ce n'est pas au
filet mais à la can à la seule force des
bras que les hommes sortent les tons
nous allons vivre cette marée
exceptionnelle avec les derniers
équipages qui pratiquent cette pêche
nous serons à bord de la rocha un bateau
de saint-jean-de-luz et nous
embarquerons sur la halle des navires de
capbreton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes le mardi 2 juillet patrick
courtiau et les marins de la halde et
n'a donc que quelques heures pour
essayer de remplir leur vivier
et les militaires ont fait un coup de
filet parce qu'après la marée descend
alors c'est moins bon et les conditions
sont pas terribles parce qu'il ya l'on
suit du 22 au reste et puis c'est
toujours des vents d'ouest ouest
nord-ouest sais pas c'est pas l'idéal va
faire remplir les viviers de menus
fretins c'est la première étape de cette
pêche artisanale car les chinchards
sardines et autres en choix sont autant
de proies faciles pour les thons rouges
mais le vent et la houle cette nuit
compliquer la tâche des marins la pêche
est maigre
le pays tanner pas au rendez vous c'est
plutôt mauvais signe pour la suite je
regardais jamais rien changé et c'est
juste les inquiétudes de rester à la
maison
il monte petit à petit
[Musique]
soit encore timide
à deux heures de navigation vers le sud
en direction de l'espagne
nous retrouvons didier martinez et
l'équipage de l'aéro chats ils sont au
large de san sebastian à la barre de sa
vieille coque en bois
didier martinez qui n'a droit qu'à 16
tonnes de thon rouge pour respecter les
quotas d'une espèce menacée avoir
empêché le temps
ça va
tu changes ton comportement quand tu
vois le temps sais pas c'est comme ça
c'est le
feeling je ne sais pas je t'explique que
ça c'est quelqu'un qui va augmenter
quelqu'un qui fait enfin pêcheurs il est
huit heures du matin cela fait
maintenant plus de trois heures qui sont
à la recherche des thons sous la mer un
bond impressionnant de plusieurs
centaines de thons rouges se dirige vers
la surface en quête de nourriture
[Musique]
allah
il est en mission
par exemple sortait de la mémoire
alors là d'ici quelques secondes les
canards vont enfin savoir si oui ou non
les tons sont affamés aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez allez
les jets d'eau c'est pour que c'est pour
brouiller au bruit faut pas que nous
voyons donc ça le temps ils ne voient
pas c'est pour nous cacher en fait sur
sa une il est calme ni l'économie rien
il dit les hameçons
les poissons sont bien là à portée de
cannes
mais déjà les problèmes commencent un
navire de plaisance rôde dans les
parages
de francs 0,7 a reculé de yack civière
je la croise les trades la chorale de
roost par dallas
posté à aa
bah
pas loin
vous êtes arrêté parce que
passer devant la tâche essentielle sur
les listes
le croissant et encore
pour ça qu'il a pour elle
je suis là ils ont suivi parce qu'ils
attendent que non ça on s'en aille et
ils viennent y passe
il passe par des rires avec les lignes
pour ça si j'ai le temps en deux ou
plusieurs n'est pas le cas la pêche
avait pourtant bien démarré mais à cause
de ces plaisanciers de malheur il leur
faudra sans doute plusieurs heures de
traque avant de retoucher un banc à 100
km à vol d'oiseau en direction du nord
ouest
nous retrouvons patrick courtiau sur la
halde ena il essaye de savoir où se
trouve le bateau de didier je n'ai pas
de mal de temps que je n'avais pas de
garde
quand les bateaux de capbreton ça n'est
décidément pas un jour de chance
cherchez regarder cela fait des heures
et des heures qui le sillonnent une
large zone à l'ouest de cap breton et
toujours rien à l'horizon
patrick le patron a beau avoir le nez
sur ses sonars il ne détecte pas l'ombre
d'un bacha ce frétillement des cuma la
surface qui indique la présence d'un
banc de thons en chasse
c'est sûr que c'est pas facile de
rentrer
rentrée avait des frais et sa poisse en
national au vote et le pire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les dauphins sont eux
aussi de la partie pour les pêcheurs de
thon c'est un très mauvais présage
pourtant là-bas au loin la et rocha est
entouré d'oiseaux tous les canneurs sont
à leur poste
il est 15 heures didier martinez a enfin
retrouvé la trace d'un immense banc de
thons rouges une meute affamée qui
semble bien décidé à ne pas lâcher son
bateau d'une semelle
les hommes de l'aéro chavon canet
jusqu'à l'épuisement car la vente du
thon rouge représente plus de 50% du
chiffre d'affaires de l'année
cette pêche fait vivre des dizaines de
familles sur la côte basque
mais avec les maigres quotas que leur
impose la commission du thonidés les
canneurs savent que chaque campagne est
peut-être la dernière
zanga
on dit qu'à la chine ou en basse de la
meech ça veut dire qu'il a il a reçoit
qui prévalent en galerie il vient des
fois il vient de manger le là bas ils
marchent pas la maison mais c'est un peu
l'art celle du perdu après 30 minutes de
pêche et freiner le banc de thons
abandonne là et rocha afin de poursuivre
sa migration vers le nord
[Musique]
en chemin les poissons vont soudainement
se diriger vers les impacts leur jette
les pêcheurs de la halde ena l'habit de
lumière
[Musique]
cette fois les canards de capbreton ne
laisseront pas passer leur chance
même patrick le patron est sur le pont
[Musique]
la nation
leur patience aura finalement payé en 20
minutes et à raison d'une prise toutes
les 15 secondes le pont de la halde ena
est recouvert de ton mail ajoute
s'arrête aussi vite qu'elle a commencé
il est 17 heures
aujourd'hui la traque des bancs de thons
a été interminable mais il semble qu'à
bord de la halde ena les résultats de la
pêche soit à la hauteur de tous les
espoirs
direction la criée de ciboure principal
port de débarquement du thon rouge de
l'atlantique 160
170 et en dehors de suite de tonnes
[Musique]
ici des affaires maritimes redoutent la
fraude et le dépassement des quotas de
la cale des navires au marquage des
poissons les canneurs sont sous haute
surveillance car de grosses sommes
d'argent sont en jeu
les autorités européennes ne font pas
dans le détail lorsqu'il s'agit de
protéger la ressource et les canards
basque comme didier martinez se voient
appliquer les mêmes règles que les
grands thoniers méditerranéens qui font
des razzias dans les stocks de thon
rouge
pado
à force à force nous rentrer le couteau
dans la plaie sans arrêt sans arrêt vous
tous c'est un gâteau et puis se diminue
tout doucement tout nous sommes
annoncées ont interdit la choix ont été
remis le temps ont été relus tout péché
un jour il y aura le temps ils vont
venir devant la bella et il y aura plus
personne pour les péchés ce métier
traditionnel il va être perdu ça c'est
sûr certains à ceux qui ne la csu le
métier va s'opérer pourrait tout là bas
avec leurs équipages
didier et patrick or ont capturé un peu
plus de trois tonnes de thon rouge en
une journée
cet été-là la saison n'aura duré que
deux mois à peine
en attendant la prochaine campagne
les derniers kanner vont devoir se
battre afin de conserver leurs quotas de
prises ils savent qu'ils ne pèsent pas
bien lourd dans la balance des
négociations
mais à l'image du poisson qu'ils
traquent nos pêcheurs basques ont de la
mitch de l'énergie à revendre
[Musique]